[Musique]
va y avoir beaucoup de changements il ya
quelques jours j'étais à paris pour
regarder sur un écran la nouvelle
conférence de richard ue qui nous
présentait le nouveau smartphone de
huawei notamment le regarder ce que j'ai
là le nouveau smartphone de mauvaise et
le huawei make x s
mais pas que surtout pour présenter leur
nouvelle stratégie en terme de conquête
pour me dire vraiment se positionner en
troisième acteur au niveau des stores
après l'app store après le plextor il y
à la galerie de hawaii dans la galerie
elle n'est pas toute nouvelle elle
existe déjà en chine il si en europe
elle n'est pas particulièrement
pertinente et on l'a vu notamment
lorsque j'ai testé le mec 30 premiers
quelques jours c'était une espèce de
coquille vide un excellent smartphone
super techno vraiment très très bel
appareil mais qu'il sent le plextor ne
servait pas à grand chose
on a un produit qui est vraiment très
très mou qui pourrait être une référence
s'il n'y avait pas ce problème de google
savait pas ce problème de plextor s'il
n'y avait pas ce problème du fait que
vous ne pouvait strictement rien
installer des services google
ces conférences a eu lieu sur un écran
parce que vous n'êtes pas sans savoir
que le mwc le grand salon de la
téléphonie mobile a été annulée il ya
quelques jours à cause du coronavirus
néanmoins la conf de huawei a eu lieu
sur place à barcelone
elle doit avoir lieu le dimanche elle a
eu lieu le lundi quelques journalistes
étaient sur place et nous en france on
s'est tous regroupés dans une seule
grande salle pour regarder la conférence
sur écran et tout ça à cause du
coronavirus sans ça je dédie expliquer
pourquoi lors de ma vidéo coronavirus
attaquant d'angers où je vous donnais un
peu ma perspective par rapport à un
potentiel annulation du salon des
voiliers comme quoi j'étais pas planter
sa soul et même la question de se dire
est ce que le mwc aura lieu est ce que
mwc 2020 existera alors aujourd'hui on
va parler de ça aujourd'hui on va parler
d'un sujet très très très très très
important très central qui va changer
beaucoup de chose à tout de suite pas
aujourd'hui mais cette année ça va
commencer un petit pas changé surtout
dans les années à venir par rapport au
changement de stratégie globale de vos
reer vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que
depuis l'année dernière
les etats unis ont placé huawei sur les
listes d'entreprises avec lesquelles on
ne peut pas travailler
en gros c'est devenu un indésirable il
soupçonne effectivement d'espionner pour
le compte de pékin donc pour que
l'entreprise américaine puisse
travailler avec moi oui elle doit
demander une
dérogation autorisation spéciale ce qui
pour l'instant toujours été refusée à
google donc huawei ne peut pas utiliser
le playsport ne peut pas utiliser les
services google a juste accès à une
version en accès libre d'android dont
vous avez toujours android aujourd'hui
sur les smartphones de huawei mais vous
n'avez absolument pas de plextor ni
aucun service pas de maps pas de gmail
pas de youtube pas dossier ça pas de
compagnie pile vous pouvez donc installé
aucune application présente simple et
sort parce qu a pas de paix store tout
simplement
donc ça c'est quand même relativement
dommage historiquement est depuis
toujours et encore aujourd'hui
actuellement la chine c'est vraiment le
hardware le matériel fabrication des
smartphones se font là bas quelles que
soient les marques
il a quelques-unes en inde mais de toute
façon c'est en asie mais plus
précisément en chine que le savoir-faire
et et toute la partie logicielle était
plutôt du côté des états unis avec
effectivement le plextor de google avec
effectivement l'app store d'apple
on avait donc ces deux grands pôles avec
beaucoup aussi d'applications qui sont
très connu ou connaissent et facebook
d'instagram jours passent et compagnie
youtube tout ça c'est plutôt du côté
américain
sauf qu effectivement avec tous ces
changements qui son père est pour ou à
louer on voit qu'il ya un déséquilibre
puisqu'ils n'ont plus accès au pool us
ce qui était relativement compliqué pour
eux donc quoi on va essayer plusieurs
tentatives pour pouvoir travailler avec
google et on espérait la levée de
l'embargo skins est globalement jamais
arrivé pour l'instant ils sont toujours
sur la liste noire et ça se décale à
chaque fois de mois en mois sur toujours
sur la liste noire est donc pour
l'instant rien ne laisse croire qu'il
pourrait à l'avenir travailler de
nouveau avec google bien que google
demande des dérogations mais pour
l'instant sur toujours refusé vous vous
et préparez donc sa contre attaque
depuis plusieurs mois et ils ont
présenté lundi leur nouvelle arme
d'attac qui à mon avis va être
extrêmement fracassantes et va changer
beaucoup de choses il ya donc une contre
attaque en trois étapes trois étapes je
vais un peu loin au niveau de la la
prospective je me projette mais pour moi
c'est vraiment trois étapes la toute
première étape celle qui a été annoncée
lundi c'est effectivement l'ouverture
globale de la galerie le store de huawei
huawei s'enorgueillit et ils ont raison
dire on est le troisième sport au niveau
international après l'app store d'apple
après le plextor de google voici la
galerie de huawei il se place donc dans
le top 3 de toute façon il n'ya pas
globalement
coup beaucoup beaucoup de concurrence là
dessus on voyait qu'elle effectivement
ce duo entre d'un côté apple avec un os
particuliers keyyo est c'est avec leur
machine s'est donc arrêtée qu'au système
assez fermé ce qui globalement ne gêne
pas google dingle action plextor il est
multi smartphone multimarques et c'est
justement ça qui pourrait bien changer à
l'avenir je monte rapidement sur mon
patron prolab galerie c'est ça alors
j'ai pas la nouvelle icône pourtant j'ai
bien les mises à jour vous arrivez donc
dans votre catalogue applicatif avec
votre différentes applications vous
connaissez cette hausse store après
c'est tout ce qui est plus classique
vous allez avoir pas mal de choses alors
que nous on n'en sait effectivement
qu'on pouvait retrouver bfm
voyez vous avez bfm on a michelin un
voyage on accueille lot on à l'express
en lacets discount twitter on n'a pas
facebook on n'a pas un stade g
il ya plein d'applications qui sont pas
encore présentes c'est un catalogue
effectivement fait pour la chine à la
base mais qui ne va cesser de croître
j'imagine qu'ils ont effectivement une
version différente entre la chine et
entre l'europe et le reste du monde
simplement parce que la censure chinoise
par rapport à certaines applications
donc est ce qu'il y aura une version
propre chine contre le reste du monde ça
on n'en parlera plus tard c'est donc une
nouvelle strate
mais on a effectivement confirmé chez
huawei que quoi qu'il se passe même si
les états unis lèvent leur embargo est
un mec notamment google de retravailler
avec huawei il ne faut pas machine
arrière c'est acté c'est décidé cette
fois ci ils ne remettront pas le plextor
c'est terminé on ne trouva pas le pstore
sur les nouveaux smartphones de huawei
on va donc avoir la galerie la galerie
ses 1,2 million d'applications
à l'heure actuelle et ça ne va cesser de
croître ces 400 millions d'utilisateurs
dans 170 pays
l'idée pour voir ouais c'est vraiment de
mettre le paquet pour qu'il y ait de
plus en plus d'utilisateurs pour qu'il y
ait plus en plus d'utilisateurs il faut
qu'ils aient de plus en plus
d'applications et il faut retrouver les
gros applications qu'on retrouve
actuellement dans le plextor et qu'on ne
retrouve pas aujourd'hui dans la galerie
quand je vous parle de gros application
c'est facebook c'est instagram c'est
twitter youtube et à mon avis on peut
oublier ces pays on ne trouvera pas
justement pour youtube vous inquiétez
pas si vous le voulez vous pouvez la
voir par votre navigateur internet vous
connecter vous avez youtube vous avez
vos vidéos en plein écran
oui parce que youtube vous pouvez la
voir sur www.youtube.com donc vous
n'êtes pas obligé d'avoir l'application
est en plus un petit hack qui est très
malin de la part de ben oui c'est que
vous pouvez à partir de votre navigateur
créer un petit raccourci sous forme
d'icônes que vous retrouverez sur votre
smartphone comme si vous aviez une
application donc en gros vous cliquez
vous fera course et qui va s'ouvrir dans
votre navigateur
il votre compte youtube c'est plutôt
malin concernant les emails gmail vous
pouvez complètement les paramétrer 2
la messagerie vous avez dans un
smartphone certains services que vous
n'aurez pas comme google maps mais il ya
des alternatives qui fonctionne alors
l'objectif pour moi c'est de recruter 5
millions de développeurs pour que la
galerie est une réelle existence en
dehors des frontières de chine
pour ça ils vont investir pas moins de
j'ai pris mes notes et électriciens
patrie par coeur ils vont investir pas
moins de 1,5 milliard d'euros
c'est colossal et ils vont créer pas
moins de 100 événements dédiés aux
développeurs dont un se tiendra en
france le 27 mars prochain pour parler
aux développeurs français le lendemain
du lancement des p 40 donc avec volonté
extrêmement forte de venir conquérir ce
terrain-là d'être présente dans ok on a
toujours eu sur le playsport on va vous
aider à migrer on va mettre les moyens
pour que vous veniez ce soit très rapide
simple pour vous soyez présent également
dans notre habit alive d'ailleurs il a
mon pote michael josh de gadgets match
qui a été voir richard yeux parce que
l'ue était présent à la conférence à
barcelone et il lui a posé la question
quid des applications populaires comme
facebook twitter instagram est riche et
rios lui a répondu que facebook twitter
et instagram devrait très bientôt
présents dans les gares et donc on voit
que même des entreprises américaines
devraient pouvoir être présent dans la
galerie
donc on va trouver certains géants
américains dans le catalogue
d'applications de huawei ce qui lui
paraîtra de décoller et trouver un vrai
aura internationale pour là on va
effectivement qu'à toute la machine qui
s'est mise en marche pour la
communication globale autour de ça pour
dire hey on est là on existe venez on va
mettre les moyens va vous aider et donc
ça c'est la première étape pour venir
remplir le catalogue d'applications
une fois que le catalogue d'applications
est présent une fois que les
développeurs ont migré sont présents
sont partout bien évidemment ils seront
pas uniquement chez huawei ils seront
chez google mais ils seront également
chez huawei ça va permettre d'attirer
les consommateurs qui vont faire
confiance et qui vont se dire ok on va
chez huawei puisqu'il y à toutes les
applications que j'utilise et je peux me
retrouver sans aucun problème ça va donc
permettre avant tout et de revendre des
smartphones en masse puisque les
consommateurs seront rassurés puisque on
pourra retrouver ce qu'on veut et qu'on
ne sera pas privé de ses applications
préférées
mais à mon avis ça ne s'arrête pas là à
mon avis va y avoir une deuxième étape
puisque maintenant que morrow et a
réussi à faire venir
les utilisateurs les consommateurs avec
son art gallery pourquoi est-ce qu'il
continuerait à utiliser android alors
aujourd'hui android tout le monde
connaît tout le monde est rassuré par
android mais on sait très bien que
huawei a son propre os qu'ils ont
développée il ya encore des choses
probablement amélioré ses harmonies os
ça paraît très très logique dans une
deuxième étape que huawei intègre
harmonie os et non plus du tout android
au sein de ses smartphones
pourquoi pour plusieurs raisons la
première raison on voir si tu es un
petit peu le business modèle global par
rapport à android et par rapport à ses
services c'est patent de vous vendre des
choses physiques c'est surtout de
pouvoir faire de la monnaie par rapport
à vos données façon un petit peu global
un petit peu général pour vraiment
simplifié l'histoire c'est à dire ils
vont récupérer des data ils vont vendre
de la publicité ciblée souffre notamment
de leurs moteurs de recherche
et ça s'étend dans tous les domaines
donc mieux google vous connais mieux ils
savent qu'ils vous êtes mieux il pourra
proposer des campagnes de publicité
vraiment ciblées donc si vous n'utilisez
plus les services google si vous
n'utilisez plus android et bien qu'est
ce qui va se passer ils auront beaucoup
moins de données sur vous ça deviendrait
donc moins pertinent pour les annonceurs
devenir communiqué par leurs billets
alors on n'en est pas là de toute façon
google aujourd'hui c'est le moteur de
recherche ultra numéro un donc les
données ils les ont ils vous connaissent
ils connaissent même très très très bien
mais si vous l'utilisez plus android
il se peut qu'il veut connaissent un
petit peu moins bien ce soit différent
et qu'elle donne change donc ça peut
être une vraie opportunité pour voir où
est de positionner ensuite harmonie os
vous pourriez donc avoir à l'avenir tout
cas moi c'est ce que je ferais je vois
vraiment comme ça arbonne ios la galerie
dessus et vous soyez dans l'écosystème
complet de huawei huawei s'inscrit comme
un acteur à part entière de la même
manière que le fait aujourd'hui apple
avec ios avec son catalogue
d'applications et son propre matériel
d'autant plus que huawei a ses propres
puces fabriquées par son entreprise high
silicone les puces kirin donc ils
viendraient complètement indépendant à
la manière d'un apple mais pourquoi
s'arrêter en si bon chemin dès lors que
huawei sera complètement indépendant et
autonome il pourrait proposer leurs os
ou leur catalogue d'applications à
d'autres marques
alors je sais pas si vous avez marre
adema vidéo il ya quelques temps que ça
plaît la morne du plessis tort ou
comment la chine veut tuer google vous
présenter une nouvelle alliance qui
s'appelle la global développeurs
services alliance la gd
à sa qui regroupe plusieurs entreprises
chinoises pour avoir un peu une
concurrence à l'avenir par rapport à
google par rapport au ps store cette
alliance regroupe au pot vivo shiomi
et il y avait ou et huawei il n'y ait
plus si vous allez sur leur site ils n'y
sont plus il y était au début mais se
sortiraient du projet huawei justement à
dessiner sa stratégie en travaillant
tous seuls mais ça me paraît extrêmement
pertinent que huawei ensuite elle
proposait ses services aux autres
constructeurs chinois en leur disant
regardez on a une vraie alternative
chinoise à ce qui existe par rapport à
la concurrence américaine par rapport à
google par rapport à apple
venez on va nous mettre en place notre
propre solution arrêter d'utiliser les
services google d'arrêter d'utiliser
android et travailler avec nous alors
effectivement il faut quand même qu'il
s'est passé beaucoup de choses il faut
que christophe d'application soit énorme
il faut qu'il y ait tout le monde de
suivre ce soir tout simple il faudra
quelques années mais ça me paraîtrait
logique que huawei se positionne comme
google aujourd'hui avec son propre os
son propre catalogue d'applications et
qu'ils aillent le propose en tout cas à
d'autres marques sont aux pauvres vivent
oraux ou encore shiomi des rythmes et du
one + et d'autres pourquoi pas on voit
qu'une vraie évolution du marché s'était
très vite entre 2019
l'embargo américain sur moi ou et 2020
la réaction qui est structuré de huawei
il va se passer beaucoup de choses
en plus on a eu des chiffres attendus
doivent les chiffres sont là on a eu des
chiffres ont été donnés lors de la
conférence de presse ils sont vraiment
intéressants parce qu'effectivement on
aurait tendance à se dire que de toute
façon où elle est un petit peu dans le
mal suite à ce qui lui arrive et cherche
en même temps que je vous parle astuces
utiles ce qui lui arrive et qui a une
vraie perte de chiffre d'affaires ils
ont effectivement vendu moins de
smartphones qui vendait en début d'année
avec le p 30
le mec 30 pro c'est idiot mais sombre et
des fictions cas extrêmement intéressant
en 2009 16,8 pour cent des smartphones
livrés dans le monde entier sont des
smartphones de huawei en france en 2010
neuf mois où elle représente au niveau
des smartphones 18,8 pour cent n'est pas
de marcher de smartphones
ils ont une augmentation de 26,2 pour
cent entre 2018 et 2019 et au quatrième
trimestre 2000
19 ils représentaient 18 8% des parts de
marché on parle donc effectivement du
moment où l'embargo america étaient
présents donc ça veut dire que wes porte
leur est globalement plutôt bien donc ça
veut dire qu'il ya une vraie confiance
du consommateur est une vraie
connaissance en tout cas de la marque
pommée comme étant une marque innovante
pour ça c'est pour extrêmement forte
tout ça s'inscrit dans une stratégie
globale qu'ils ont appelé la un plus
suit plus
n vous explique un peu le concept très
rapidement un c'est le smartphone c'est
le smartphone qui est au centre de
l'écosystème c'est l'objet technologique
que vous avez toujours avec vous c'est
donc le centre le smartphone c'est votre
extension c'est vous le plus chez huawei
cher ou un chien jouait déjà montré
notamment au niveau d'un ordinateur
c'est le macbook des 15 vous avez donc
allé voir la vidéo si ce n'est pas déjà
le cas pour comprendre comment
fonctionne votre quotidien kpata de
votre smartphone vous pouvez partager et
communiquer avec tous les devices de
huawei donc les plus vite c'est les
petits pots logis de produits ou des
pouvoirs retrouver dans cet écosystème
alors vous avez dedans réalité augmentée
réalité virtuelle pour ça ça va se
développer c'est pas forcément pour tout
de suite
ce sont les tablettes ce sont les pc
c'est là téléviseur c'est la monde
connecté ce sont les hauts parleurs ce
sont les écouteurs avec les freebox 3
vous avez ensuite le plus le plus c'est
la 4g la sagesse et la connectivité
globale pour communiquer avec le monde
extérieur et le n correspond à tous les
partenaires vous et pouvoir avoir à
l'extérieur c'est à dire que pour
résumer un peu ça qui par un peu
nébuleux pour comprendre vous avez donc
votre smartphone communique avec les
huit catégories de produits autour vu
par huawei qui eux vont communiquer
grâce à la 5g et à la 4g et avec tous
les partenaires extérieurs que ce soit
du gaming de la vidéo des imprimantes
des mavs des voitures connectées toussa
toussa toussa
voilà un peu la ligne de route pour
huawei pour les années à venir qu'ils
ont donc pris complètement leur
indépendance leur autonomie huawei
aujourd'hui travaille seul fait route
seul fait cavalier seul
aujourd'hui huawei s'est complètement
émancipée de google je pense qu'ils vont
continuer dans les temps à venir
justement on se basant sur harmony ouais
ça prendra du temps
ça mettra du temps mais bon il va
s'imposer comme un acteur fort
indépendant libre je mets des guillemets
quand je dis ça mais qui va vraiment
pesé dans ce secteur il se place comme
un concurrent frontal par rapport à
google et je vous le disais alors
qu'elle était annoncée cet embargo
américain
c'est une grosse erreur par rapport à
google maintenant est ce qu'il y a des
liens d'espionnage ça je ne sais pas je
suis pas en mesure de le savoir mais
d'un point de vue purement stratégique
par rapport à google
c'était sûr que ça allait leur faire
extrêmement mal
on le suivra on en reparlera pour
paradou huawei avec la galerie on a
regardé réellement comment ça fonctionne
on parlera effectivement de voir où est
aussi avec les nouveaux smartphones qui
vont mettre sortir p40 p40 propre et 40
light qui devrait aller très très loin
en termes de photos dans tout ça on en
reparlera j'avais donc à vous abonner si
c'est pas déjà car bien évidemment a
blessé des jolies pouces été blessées
toutes vos questions et interrogations
en bas et puis mourir et beaucoup
d'amour moi je m'envoie un paquet sur ce
je donne rendez vous dès demain demain
après demain on va continuer à parler
tech portez vous bien des bisous ciao
[Musique]